[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Jade what
did you do I didn't do anything you did
you super did look I posted a video on
Facebook specifically about how like
zero credit scores work and these folks
came for my life John dude they were
showering you with the hater so I was
thinking you know what I usually stay
out of the comments or I'm like pretty
you know just nonchalant about it but
these these comments were extra and I
was like you know what I need to I need
to I need to clap back on this so let's
play the video so you guys can just see
how innocent what I said was and you can
be on my side and then we'll chop it up
all right let's do it it usually takes
about a year to see your credit score go
down to absolute zero if you completely
stop borrowing money and here's the
thing if you dilly dally with this and
you're like I'm going to keep that one
credit card open it's never going to go
to zero you're just going to going to
have a bad credit score and then when
you try to go buy a house you're going
to run into problems look yeah I stand
by that I stand by that message I
approve that message all right I'm going
to read some of the haterade all right
read it Chad says these people are crazy
zero credit score is not even possible
okay uh Tim says this is absolutely not
correct you need to raise your credit
score not lower it this explains so much
about some people M Derek says this kind
of crap's annoying while it's possible
to buy a house without a credit score it
isn't worth the Hoops okay better off
with a credit score the next one's my
favorite yeah Jacob says says the woman
with tons of assets to lean on and has
no need for crit card I can't I can't
I'm coming out of my I'm coming out of
my seat right now because and I did
reply to that when I was like oh you
must not know me or my story if you
think I came from wealth and assets are
you kidding me I got to throw my pin
across the room because hold on hold on
this this cat says I swear the Ramsay
team's advice on credited is the
stupidest be beep ever good luck getting
approved for Jack be beep with no credit
that's the whole point here's my thing
here's my thing John and this is crazy
to me people would rather be
right about what they think and about
what they know then be free then be
happy then be better off in life they
they'd rather be right about the fact
that there's no other way to get ahead
in society than to be strapped with debt
for eternity yes like you have to play
the debt game that's the only it's the
only way to Make It in America is to
have a credit score are you kidding me
you'd rather be right about that and I'm
like really you want to be right about
something that keeps you in slavery your
entire life forever it's that important
to you and dude for all of human history
this is how governments capture their
citizens by giving them a plot of land
and saying when it's paid off then it's
all yours then next year it's like oh
well we had to raise the price on it so
uh and they do that in perpetuity and
now we wear this score like we win
something and I'm the only one the folks
in this room are some of the only ones
in the United States in the world
telling y'all hey there's a better way
and we we try to do it with love we try
to tell y'all hey there's a better way
we want you to be free we want to help
you we exist to help the people outside
of these walls and it's crazy that
people clap back on me like I'm trying
to hurt them and they're not clapping
back at the credit collectors they're
not clapping back at FICO or Experian or
TransUnion they're yelling at me when
I'm the one I'm the one going hey
there's a way that you don't have to
play this stupid game you don't have to
Rack your family with debt you don't
have to you know rob Peter to pay Paul
and move this money over here and keep
your credit around for x amount of years
with x amount of varieties of credit
with x amount of percentage use like
that is a game and the goalpost is
constantly moving and one of the things
I noticed that they were mad at me as I
said hey if you're going to run our plan
like run it to the end zone like do it
all the way don't do this mess of well
I'm going to pay off my credit but I'm
going to keep a couple of cards open or
keep that one card open just in case CU
that'll jack your credit even worse
right because there are ways that
they're measuring your credit it's not
just hey have one credit card open you
have to utilize that credit and you have
to keep it around for a long time and
you have to make sure the percentage is
Right otherwise yeah you'll have a score
but it won't be great it'll probably be
pretty bad and the fact is having a
I'mma say it and I'mma scream it till
the cows come home having a zero credit
score is just as good in my opinion
better than having a 750 or a 800
because I don't have to play the game of
debt I get to be my own woman my own man
my husband and we're autonomous and we
are free and we don't have to be slaves
to the system so if you don't like that
you can go ahead and put that Yol back
on and they can Y and you'll just pull
the plow of debt for them and you can do
that the rest of your life I'm not going
as for me in my house making other
people Rich at your expense look hey I I
I can we run through this real quick
yeah these people are crazy zero credit
score is not even possible you're false
false it's false once you pay off your
debt like I said it takes about and you
close the accounts you've got to close
them it takes about 6 to 12 months for
your credit score to roll to zero that's
how it goes this is absolutely not
correct you need to raise your credit
score not lower it why false why yeah
you tell me why so that one day you can
go get on both knees and hold your hands
up and say dear lender please please and
they'll say well let me let me look in
my secret file and see what your score
is yeah instead of sitting down with
your wife and when your air conditioner
goes out and you have become your own
bank over years which is what took me
and my wife and your argument is not
please please can I it's you call I'm
not calling you call I don't want to
call you call I love it that's that's
the most annoying fight you have yeah
right and I think people forget the fact
that when you decide John like Hey we're
going to pay off our debt that
simultaneously means and we're not going
back into debt and we're not doing this
thing called credit anymore and the
biggest argument is yeah but if you
don't have a credit score how are you
going to live and the biggest two areas
that people are thinking about are cars
and living situation right can you buy a
car without credit yes you can it's
called buying a car in cash and I'm not
talking about that you always have to
save $40,000 or $50,000 to buy the
newest model the cars that Sam warshaw
and Jade warshaw Drive are from 2013 and
I think we paid less than I don't know
20,000 for both yeah each of them that's
how you do this you don't have and don't
get me wrong I could have way more car
than that John at this point in my life
I just don't care about it that much so
don't tell me it's not possible you save
up your money and it takes time uh let
me just say this my husband and I for
the first time in our marriage are a
two-car family and that happened last
year because that's just the life we
chose we didn't have to do that for that
long but we said you know what I don't
care about going into debt over cars and
when we feel like paying up cash and
buying a second car we will and that's
what you're talking about you just
choose it was it was up until this this
year I I went from a 96 to a 2012 and I
was driving 2012 forever yeah and Dave
just just Dave as my friend goes hey I
know what I pay you what are you doing
and I was like he's like you're trying
to like make a point I go I I I honestly
don't care I don't care and it was only
that I was like I'm going to get and by
the way I went all in on a Highlanders
know I mean and dude every day I get in
it I smile so big like like I've beat
somebody like I've won some game and my
buddies are like it's it's not it's not
a cool car John come on you know what I
mean but it's like I know but it it
doesn't have a CD player in it anymore
right here's the deal when you unhook
yourself from the external expectation
yeah my wife likes me and you know how I
know she likes me because she was dating
me when I was driving an 88 Tel easy
hatchback so I know this is love right
and that when we were making it when we
were when we when Dave was paying us
more money than any delon's had ever
wrapped their head
around I I didn't need to prove anything
to anybody no it's not a game right it's
like yeah I was able to Cobble together
the money and pay for that in cash and
it's just it's mine the money see what
I'm saying what you buy it doesn't
determine your worth hey uh one more
thing um what about housing let me hit
this right quick people think you can't
buy a house with a zero credit score yes
you can it's called manual underwriting
I did it John deloney did it George
Campell did it I know Rachel Cruz did it
all these folks did it all you need is
payment history 12 months showing your
trade Lin cell phone bills utilities you
need actual money you need to show 12
months of bank statements and just your
last 30 days but so many Hoops it's not
it's almost the same as the normal
process it's not hey by the way
Churchill Mortgage is a place to go guys
yes and man if you just weren't so rich
uh you wouldn't able to talk like this
Jade